the bank of England now you've been busy
printing money with King Charles III's
face on it but little is known about how
much money he makes or how much he's
worth
he's inherited land properties and other
items from Queen Elizabeth II and one
estimate suggests his fortune is some
745 million dollars but a lack of
transparency from the royals makes it
difficult to determine exactly how rich
Charles is here's what we do know about
his sources of income and what it all
adds up to
Charles has always had something of an
entrepreneurial spirit in 1990 he
launched his duchy Originals range of
organic oat biscuits which later
expanded to other products made on the
prince's estate those products were
eventually sold exclusively in British
Supermarket waitrose as part of a
partnership deal
the brand reported profits of over four
million dollars last year all of which
was donated to the Prince of Wales
charitable Foundation
as the Prince of Wales and heir to the
throne Charles also controlled the duchy
of Cornwall an estate with net assets of
1.3 billion dollars which covers almost
000 acres of land across England
its net assets have increased in value
by 44 since 2012. with Charles seeing
his income from the estate increased 25
over the past decade he raked in 28.3
million dollars last year mostly through
rent from commercial and residential
properties
now that Charles is king the duchy of
Cornwall along with its multi-million
dollar income goes to his eldest son
William he succeeds me as duke of
Cornwall and takes on the
responsibilities for the duchu Cornwall
which I have undertaken for more than
five decades
Charles in Harry
Caster from his mother worth around 800
million dollars it consists of more than
000 Acres of commercial Agricultural and
Residential Properties in England and
Wales and provides a private income for
the Monarch the late Queen earned 29.7
million dollars from it last year and
there's nothing to suggest her son won't
take home a similar amount he also
doesn't have to pay any taxes on dutchie
Revenue though he will follow in the
Queen's footsteps and opt to pay income
tax after deducting money spent on
official duties
but the duchy of Lancaster isn't the
Monarch's only source of income or even
their most valuable
a large amount of King Charles's income
derives from something called The
Sovereign Grant here's how that works in
the 1700s the monarchy handed over
revenues from swathes of land to the
government known as the crown estate
these days the crown estate makes money
on a range of assets from retail
property to golf courses and even
offshore wind farms those assets are
valued at around 20 billion dollars I
take this opportunity to continue the
tradition of surrendering the hereditary
revenues including the crown of state to
my government for the benefit of all
in return for The Sovereign Grant
every year the government pays a
percentage of the profits made on those
assets back to the monarchy last year it
totaled more than 106 million dollars
that was used to fund the Queen's
official duties and maintain Royal
residences including Buckingham Palace
which is kept in a trust for the
reigning monarch the king does not
personally own the properties making up
the crown estate and can't sell them for
his own financial gain unlike the two
properties we know he inherited from his
mother Sandringham house in Norfolk and
Balmoral Castle in Scotland which has
been in the royal family since 1852.
the 80 000 acre Preserve in the Scottish
Highlands has since been the holiday
Retreat for Britain's ruling families
[Music]
the two Estates pass from Monarch to
Monarch until Edward VII's abdication in
1936 when a financial settlement saw
them transferred to his brother and
Charles's grandfather George VI each was
valued between 66 and 79 million dollars
by one Royal expert although a potential
market price for this kind of asset is
difficult to determine last year a
cottage on the Sandringham estate was
made available on Airbnb as a holiday
rental by Norfolk highways visitors can
book the garden house for just over one
thousand dollars per night Norfolk
hideaways couldn't say how much of any
revenue from the listing went back to
the royal family the Balmoral estate in
Scotland also rents out Cottages in
addition to selling ticketed tours the
king could also have inherited Queen
Elizabeth's personal Investment
Portfolio the value of which is
undisclosed
the palace won't comment on the
Monarch's wealth or the contents of
Wills they say it's a private matter we
do know that Charles paid no inheritance
tax on any of the assets passed to him
by the queen but unlike other UK
citizens royal family members don't have
to make their Wills public this means we
can't determine what Charles inherited
from his mother or father Prince Philip
so we may never know what is truly worth